i've spent a bag on it
i've spent the whole bag on it what am i
going to tell my missus
what am i going to say what am i going
to do
my finances are dodging i was lost in
the drama of it and now i've knotted and
i've just got a jar on my face there's
there's not everywhere i think and i'm a
bad guy
now what have i done
[Music]
it's monday fun day you know what it is
bro
you're chilling with your boys james and
and fuegs and um
i already know you've clicked play and
you're snuggling in yeah and you're
gassed your gas you've
sorry
don't think it's mad yeah that like
this is like a time warp thing in what
sense so they've
already before they're listening to us
speaking right now they're all they've
already heard [ __ ] that we haven't said
yet
that's crazy considering we're recording
it now goodbye satay recording it right
now i'm speaking it right now but
they've already heard [ __ ] that i've not
even thought of saying
in the intro and they've gassed already
that's crazy actually crazy that's
messing with my head that is messing
with my head now you said that
that's insane that's insane that's
disgraceful stuff but i hope it was
funny whatever i said
um or whatever foo had said i hope it
was funny
um
guys before we go any further we already
know what to do need to pause the thing
i need to quickly scurry over
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
um sign up to patreon it's three pound a
month it's 10p a day run the people run
the p you already know what to do um
enjoy those bonus episodes every
thursday if you're not a punk [ __ ]
basically basically if you're not a
[ __ ] head on over to um
patreon.com sign up and uh get jiggy
with us on thursdays
um
as well if you're watching on youtube
two fingers of death you already know
that bring the notification bell click
on that big red button subscribe
and um chat sitting in the comments you
already know what to do we've seen a
couple of manchester united family girl
church yesterday as well what do you
have a day just a little trip
that's what i said
that's hilarious yeah yeah that is
straight to the point
um so yeah man keep traps in the
comments i want i'm i want wedding
pictures in my dms bro that's what i
want where did pictures bro this
happened because of you yeah yeah i want
to see the thing in the comments and
here we are um
yeah man i want them them dim them
dinner table things when you run the
in-laws and they're like oh how did you
me chirps in the comments
come on through sng through the sng
vibes man that platform just just made
us there we go so um
obviously guys and then
if you are listening to the smooth
mellow voices on spotify google podcast
apple podcast whatever it is you're
listening to um just give us a quick
review yeah we're saying study on the
five stars as it is uh and let's let's
keep that train going um leave us some a
nice message in there as well that would
be lovely all right guys and without any
further ado fire lord folks is hitting
you with them fire facts let's go this
week is about ksi obviously we all know
ksi um business mogul internet sensation
musician
and he's just all about round and round
youtube god yeah as well just creative
guy a creative guy he boxes all of these
things so um he has a 20 million
pound plus business right so the
youtuber who built his business empire
across many industries won youtube 150
plus million subscribers across seven
channels generating 250 000 pounds plus
a year from ads and sponsors
property is that it
says 250k a yeah 250k a year yeah from
the youtube channel from all seven
youtube channels yeah now must be more
than that bro according to this this is
what it's saying i believe it's more
than that
okay i believe it it's way more than
that but anyway sorry carry on
property he's got 10 million portfolios
with 10 million dollars sorry 10 million
plus pounds in properties with more than
13
i can't get my words out today
10 million
pounds plus portfolio is what i was
trying to say with more than 13
properties
music five million plus monthly
listeners earning millions on streaming
revenues and touring that's surprising
to me but that is very very surprising
one of his songs i don't listen to him
so i don't really know so that's very
it's a very unbiased judgment but
hey
you know say no more the numbers don't
like they don't they literally don't lie
here's what it is and it is what is you
know
boxing two pay-per-view fights that
generated over 10 million pounds for him
and companies he's got a sports drink
called prime yeah that just dropped
logan valued at 150 million plus dollars
that doesn't make sense it does just
dropped yesterday how how how
how is that worth 150 nothing bro it
just dropped 150
it don't it ain't sold nothing yet
150 million so i've got the he's doing
these evaluations i've got the follow-up
on the um
on the logan paul um collab prime so as
rivals youtuber youtubers ksi and logan
paul both earned 3 million on excess of
3 million dollars for the two fights
now as business partners they've just
launched a sports drink prime hydration
through orders from us retail stores
alone prime has already banked a
potential hundred and fifty to two
hundred million valuation in dollars
okay from pre-orders pretty ksl revealed
that [ __ ] yeah mum yeah he makes
stupid cake
you pig cake and he
it's similar
to like um
he made a quote or a statement similar
to what like money may was talking about
i was talking about the patreon episode
on um on thursday he was talking about
um
how he just strived for everything like
he was doing this he was doing that if
you want to get you have to go for it
things like that but obviously he wasn't
saying it in in that kind of yeah yeah
but he was just saying you know he's
he's gone through a lot and he's been
digging deep he's been doing stuff he's
been doing youtube since he was 16. he's
like 11 12 years into the game now bro
he's 28 29 now i think he's starting
something like that he's around our age
so he's just been in the game all right
him i have to write him
in the game i literally rate him for
like a good there's one thing he does
that i've always rated
um
in that do you know how we were speaking
about last week about how um like
chunks like slowly moving into like a
mainstream media more format and
focusing a lot less on youtube and all
that stuff especially like his own
channel yes um obviously he does like
the foot asylum stuff yes but that's
more regular than his own stuff yes so
he's looking at that this is fine this
is decision that's all good one thing
ksi does is that impresses me he's got
so much [ __ ] money but he still does
the basic [ __ ] that got him there in the
first place like he still does
dumb
reactions in his bedroom
in his little like gamer chair yeah like
trying not to laugh on youtube and stuff
like that that brings in millions and
millions and millions of views and all
that stuff but it's like
a lot of people in his position could
look at that and think why would i still
do that yeah why would i do that do you
know how much money i have brought up
why would i still do those things but
obviously he recognizes that that's what
got him there yeah and that's what's
going to keep him there and when all
this stuff blows over like if for
example like obviously
they there's prime and they sell prime
for a gazillion pounds and all that
stuff and
he will always have youtube no matter
what happens he will always have youtube
and like that
even though it probably doesn't bring in
the main money it takes a very
uh how do i say
not necessarily a very smart person but
a very like aware you have to be very
like
mentally aware
and somewhat grounded person to
understand that
people love you for this and all this
money you're making elsewhere is just
the same audience that you have here
and they're following you everywhere you
go you're not just a guy who has an
audience wherever he goes yeah you have
one audience and they stay with you yeah
and then what's what making you with
this whole thing yeah so you need to
give them what they came for and they'll
come with you for everything else as
soon as you stop giving them what they
came for then they'll stop [ __ ] with
you for everything else and i rate him
whenever i see him like uh on stuff on
like tic toc or whatever and he's still
doing like normal like reaction videos
and stuff i'm like [ __ ] hell bro like
you don't need to be here if you don't
want to bro yeah um but yeah i rate that
um
he said one thing one thing on like this
interview thing a couple weeks ago where
i was a bit like
okay what'd he say it wasn't it wasn't
what he said but it was like um he was
basically getting interviewed and they
were asking him about like crypto okay
and
i heard him saying an interview one time
that he'd put like millions like five or
six million or whatever just gave it to
a guy to build a crypto portfolio for
him and he trusted that guy i was like i
trust you whatever here's my money make
me some pee
um
and when he said that i was like [ __ ]
hell like
props yeah um and
he
was on this it looked like a red carpet
thing maybe they were interviewing
they're talking about uh
crypto and the way he was responded the
questions
made it so obvious that he has no idea
what he's talking about which is fine
but you don't need to pretend that you
do okay so in terms of they were like oh
he was like yeah man just like i just i
just think like crypto is the future and
like blockchain and
nfts and non-fungible tokens and i was
like you're saying buzz words
they all mean the same thing yeah and
you just keep saying them over and over
again hoping that it makes sense yeah
he's regarded james's
[ __ ] that doesn't that's not a coherent
sentence to make yourself sound like you
know what you're talking about
um when really i would have rated it
more if you just said to be honest i
don't really know that much about it
it's not my job to know my much about it
but i trust the people around me that do
and i trust their expertise and i invest
in the people and they invest for me and
that's what makes me successful is that
the people around me know what the [ __ ]
they're doing and i'm lucky to have him
i would have been like props yeah rather
than like making it seem like oh i know
what i'm talking about
um and that's why i'm making pete on
crypto yeah it's i would rather i go
[ __ ] play bro but this guy that's
he's been close to me for many years he
knows what he's talking about and i
trust him so i gave him my money and he
makes me richer every day that's what i
would i would rate that just um
you didn't need to do that
you know you're you're famous and rich
enough as it is you don't need to
seem cool
you are cool you're ksi true
you're okay aside
oh that's what matters they could have
said like oh we heard you're investing
in crypto
i'm ksi
and they would have been like fair
whatever on whatever question you have
for me the answer is i'm ksi
all right say
there's nothing you can do about it
and just dig their forehead or walk on
the red carpet on ksi i'm [ __ ] caked
and there's [ __ ] all you can do about it
and then just walk off and then fly
i'll fight oh they're scrapping people
would fight fam they'd scrap him
um but yeah
i was vexing the other day um this is
like the kid in me this is like a lot of
stuff i do is to appease 16 year old
james
does that make sense
hit me a lot of stuff in my life i do is
just to make 16 year old james happy
stuff that i don't necessarily care
about yeah but um
like 16 year old james would care a lot
so i'm like all right so some i was on
tick tock the other day in one of our
videos and some guy commented like
oh um
so sidemen have a a podcast right mm-hmm
so it's a subscription only podcast
which is frustrating because i don't pay
for stuff like that which i would but
yeah not for sidemen um
and then some guy commented like oh by
the way i think it's called side plus
and then some guy commented like oh
simon was chatting about you man on the
side plus the other day
i was like i saw that [ __ ] yeah i want
to see it i want to see you too i tried
to find it i was like
i don't even know where to find it oh
yeah fine because it's a subscription
thing so you'd have to go to the website
subscribe pay 6.99 whatever it is that
they charge and then listen to whatever
every episode to find a small little
snippet of one of the sidemen chatting
about you and i was like 16 year old
james would die to see this yeah and
it's like i'm never gonna of course i'm
never gonna do it
of course i'm never gonna do it but that
was cool
that was cool that is cool thank you
simon thank you he's the same brother
that holidays in the training yeah he
messaged us one time i didn't want to
expose it to the world but he did i mean
yeah was minnie minter in idm yeah bro
maybe he was i'm not confirming not
denying that the sidemen stay in our dms
bro
maybe he was maybe he wasn't
hey that's for you guys but you got to
speculate
[Laughter]
um but yeah man that's um kennesaw is a
busy guy he's a very very very busy guy
and he keeps his boys busy as well
which is a great thing his boys are
caked he keeps his boys busy and i rate
that fam he's saying like chunks and
dead man he keeps these boys busy chucks
trunks brings his mans with him
anywhere
as soon as he went over to foot asylum
yeah these men need to they need to come
in with me
it's an awful no one van it's us or no
one and they're just racking up a squad
or not injury you're racking up the
views and they're funny guys man darkest
man is a funny [ __ ] guy i'm glad you
said that dark isn't it like every
monday should be a certain creative
appreciation day
is a funny [ __ ] guy he's just on
clips alone that i've seen he's caught
me by surprise like four times with
sheer funniness yeah or like
like intelligent funny noises fire
quick fire stuff bro where i'm like
impressive yeah i always write this
sounds very egotistical of me but i
don't mean it to be i always
i'm impressed by people who can make me
laugh in a way that i could never make
anyone else laugh i hear what you're
saying so like he
they um
there's there's been times where they'll
just run a few bars at each other yes of
course and then there's times where he's
done saturn and says something i can't
feel the life of me like remember what
it would have been but it's so quick and
so spot on that i'm like i would never
be able to do that yeah that's [ __ ]
hilarious bro yeah yeah well played man
said too because him and harry they
always go back up harry panera
back and forth back and forth and he
says science said this i think it was an
episode of when they were in trunks's
yard i can't remember what they were
filming for
but they were going back and forth and i
think
um darkis said to harry
when
something along the lines of because
obviously harry's he talks about his
hairline a lot like his m hairline
and he says something along the lines of
sounds like harry's hairline yeah even
though i was gonna say darkest darkest
has got no hair
that's the only robotics he's got this
yeah
the only rebuttal what the only robot
leads his age and the way he looks and
blah blah so yeah that's the robot he
always goes for and he said
when
harry was a kid it was called burger
prince not burger king something stupid
like that
something dumb like that yeah but he's
quick yeah he's so [ __ ] quick he's
mad and he's got punch lines as well he
that that's the word for punchlines
that's the word for it bro he's got
punch lines and i'm not a punchline guy
so when i hear him smack someone with
the punchline i'm like i'm so jealous
you can do that because it's so funny so
quick i can't think that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah do stuff that quick bro
um
but yeah
so i would say today ksi and darkest man
appreciation day
well done guys thank you for for your
contributions yeah thank you to your
contributions guys because you mana you
men are doing it guess i've had enough
flowers darkest man you're honey you're
up you're up to europe well played
well
um okay guys so
it's 2022. your boys over at manscape
want to wish you a happy new year
and
we already know a six-pack is a great
new year's resolution
but how about a six-pack for your balls
let's get on that performance package
4.0 which contains the six essential
tools
for the ultimate below the waste
grooming that's six
four thousand guys have hopped on four
thousand four million million my bad
four million four thousand thousand
that's what i meant to say
[Music]
four thousand thousand
um four million men around the world are
already there with their six pack balls
they're chilling they're smooth sailing
they're clapping cheeks with no
inhibitions yeah skin on skin
interaction skin on skin that's what we
do over here so guys when you're ready
to take the next step in your evolution
all you want to do is head on over to
manscape.com use the code sng sierra
november gold oh thank you sir and
you're going to get yourself 20 off and
free shipping worldwide that's
manscape.com the code is sng that's 20
off free shipping worldwide thank you
very much for paying attention let's get
back to the episode
right that's jokes again um
real quick i want to take a sharp left
turn all right say this
sharp left hand we'll come back to that
we'll come back
we'll come back i know you want stuff i
will come back let me take a quick
diversion
i saw um well this got sent to me
funniest thing
yeah the other day so let me set the
premise
so it was on facebook that's how you
know it's sent to me
facebook apparently has some gold left
in it
[Music]
facebook apparently has gold left in
fact i'm not gonna lie to you should you
said facebook thinking oh what's this
gonna be about
i'm i'm so far removed from being from
that thing as far as i know facebook is
where you post your missing cash yeah
and that's it
yeah yeah when you can't find your cat
yeah or you want to sell some old [ __ ]
yeah yeah facebook sales garage sales
and lost cats okay
um and neighborhood watch groups
yeah that's all facebook is yeah it's
useless apparently not it's got some
gold in there okay so
that's funny some genius
decided to create an account
called customer support okay
so what they were doing is
is
whenever
um they would go onto big brands
facebook pages yes
and
where people like disgruntled customers
would
um post on there with a complaint so say
if you're on the mcdonald's page someone
would
um post a complaint
this fake account would change that icon
to the mcdonald's symbol
and their name is customer support so
they would reply as customer support
fam i've got a few examples funny as
[ __ ] okay i've seen bro okay it's it was
genius okay i like where we're going i
like where we're heading all right where
we're heading read the complaint first
part of course i will say let's see
right so
the first one
this is that new look yeah
this is the complaint i'm extremely
frustrated with the sizing of your
clothing
why do you not cater for taller girls
asos and topshop are miles ahead when it
comes to looking after its taller
customers i'm 511 and nothing you have
fits i'm sick of returning items at my
expense
it's a shame as i found the perfect
dress i won't be shopping with you again
sort it out
reply from customer support
pipe down caitlyn jenner
no fam way pipe down caitlyn jenner i'm
absolutely dying this morning had a bit
of a mad one last night proper feeling
it now with the sick face
come back in six hours after my shift
the reply how dare you make fun of my
height
nah how dare you make fun of my height
i'm actually in shock at that reply and
think it's disgusting that you think
it's acceptable to speak to a customer
like that hilarious
there's bearing them no
bro there's bear in them
i would be cackling as i'm typing away
cat killing this one
this is at mcdonald's
this morning i ordered a porridge from
the drive-through then was asked to park
in bay parking it took five minutes to
arrive making me late for work and when
i opened it it was lukewarm
how hard is it to have porridge ready in
the morning
reply from customer support how hard is
it to get your goldilocks ass up a
little bit earlier
she replied i'm actually speechless they
replied again i wish you were
sick bro sick
hilarious ah i can imagine the faces of
the customers when they see the
notification and read the first line
shell shock because i already know
they're all 47 year old women they're
all parrots yeah yeah i can't believe it
they can't believe the audacity of the
responses bro
this one at marks and spencer's
terrible service in the queensgate
peterborough store two staff gossiping
while serving me it's not the service i
expect from m s one of the girls was
called claire but i didn't see the other
girl's name very rude
reply from customer support don't be a
grass
standard femme don't be a glass
then reply excuse me is that an attempt
at humor very unprofessional i spent a
lot of money with you
why wouldn't i complain all grass when
it's my money that pays wages
reply from customer support
snitches get stitches
nah
nah
bro shell shocked
um oh this one had me dead bro this one
had me dead hit me
tga this is uh tgi fridays yeah
i would like to uh i'd just like to say
a big thank you to susie who served us
today at tgi fridays in nottingham
um
she couldn't do enough for us and was
excellent with the kids she deserves a
big pat on the back the jack daniels
sauce was also delicious as ever
reply from customer support
i'm afraid we had to let suzy go
we caught her [ __ ] in the jd swords
again
thank you for the feedback we hope to
see you again soon bro they replied i
don't understand that's a company why
you'd say that if it even if it was true
please tell me this is some sort of
wind-up reply from customer support
unlike susie i [ __ ] you not
yo bro yo bravo that was the one fam
that was the one bravo bravo bro this
one this last one this is the last one
right
uh this is uh uh b and q yeah okay
[ __ ] b and q you know bro b and q
um i bought a verve garden hoe from you
in february but i only got around to
using it this weekend after just a few
hours i noticed at the end of the ho and
there was a crack i returned it and was
told i couldn't it couldn't be replaced
as you no longer stock it and i wasn't
eligible for a refund
their reply firm
these jose ain't loyal
i knew he was going to say something
like that i think you said ho i think
he's going to use that word
okay and then they replied
i have screenshots and i'll be sending
this to your bosses unbelievable replied
again come on man bros before hoes
that's actually fair enough facebook
yeah fam facebook apparently there's
some gold left fair enough apparently
there's some gold left fair enough
they're trying to keep up they aren't
changed
um that made me laugh but the thing is
as well is like
there's some gold left on facebook but
it's based on the the boring [ __ ]
that i said is only on facebook people
complaining to companies about their
service
shut up true
imagine
buying a lawn mower
not using it for a year
it turns out to be [ __ ]
you can't get a refund because you ain't
use it in a year your business
and then you go on facebook to complain
like
people on facebook of course that's
[ __ ] sick that's uh i don't have time
for people like that i just don't
neither do i bro i wouldn't
i would not do well working in
complaints at any company any level any
company no neither would i i wouldn't i
wouldn't be able to bite my tongue
fam wouldn't be able to remember i used
to work in martian spencer on a
christmas tempting i remember i told you
years ago worst however many weeks it
was yeah worse those many weeks yeah for
us those many weeks yeah um and they
have been working in women's clothing
women are scumbags that's all i know
they buy [ __ ] to return it
and they are so used to returning [ __ ]
that they don't get it when they can't
return it and one woman who bought like
tights or jeans or some [ __ ] something
that goes on your legs i can't remember
what it was
and she bought it to me and she's like
oh
i want to return these because they've
got like a massive tear down the side
fam
i said oh cool like have you got your
receipt nah
i got my receipt
okay
like when did you buy them etc etc have
you worn them yeah i've worn them she
said i've worn them like seven or eight
times
and but there's a massive tear down the
side like i can't wear them anymore i
want my money back and i was like
you can't have your money back like
you've worn them seven or eight times
and you don't have a receipt bro she was
kicking off like is this some kind of
[ __ ] joke obviously i'm supposed to
be able to wear jeans more than seven or
eight times
and i'm like what kind of delusion are
you what kind of dimension are you
living in yeah it's not like you wore it
once you put it on it ripped it it's not
like the first time you pulled up it
must have yeah you wore it the best part
of 10 times i'm sorry that it tore yeah
but
you can't dictate your standards of the
level of tapestry that went into this
the level of textile is not up to your
standards no one gave you a no one
there's nothing that says you can only
wear these
like you you have to be able to wear
these 20 times yeah there's nothing that
says that you've worn it eight times bro
that's your business now well she wasn't
having it she wasn't having it bro
and some people have so much energy in
their day for that they do they really
do i think i wish i had the power to
kick you out bro and ban you for life
that's what it's like in hospitality but
people complain about the stupidest
things
stupidest i can't even think of all
right now because i don't even want to
think about stuff like that but it's so
jarring man i told you about my
ex-girlfriend i know what people
complain about i know i've seen what
people complain about hospitality is un
it's unfathomable to me it's
unfathomable and unfair it's oh it is
unfair because you have to
you have to bear the part of their
stupidity
fam you literally have to like
pretend that you it's what they're doing
is okay
you can't just say like you're out of
order like you're not getting anything
for free you ate it
you ate it
it's long it is very long
it's very long out of order bro out of
order bro um but yeah you had a little
something in it
[ __ ] now yeah um
cool trash news
reality star who made 38 000 pounds a
week selling farts in a jar from their
fiance in it hospitalized for farting
too much yeah i i didn't i know the
story of her puppet in jazz but i saw
that she'd been hospitalized but i
didn't read into it or anything like
that but she's a joke bro
i don't even know she was from naida
beyonce she's from 90 days
to be fair first line former 90 day
fiance star
who made a staggering 38 bags a week
from selling her farts in a jar has
revealed she was rushed to hospital
stephanie mato used her 260k following
to sell her products which retailed at a
grand or thousand dollars or 756 pounds
a jar this is what led to her being
rushed to hospital she started
experiencing chest pains she thought she
could have been going through a heart
attack although doctors sorry although
doctors revealed it was due to her diet
she's now been advised to take a gas
suppressant medicine
which has ended her flat of flatulence
business
mato said that her family are relieved
that she can't continue to do this line
of work
look her in bed
and she looks mad
she's been far injured oh bro
look at the first one look at them look
at her in the corner in the hospital bed
oh she looks [ __ ] she's kind of paying
though she is kind of paying but like
i'm not buying a farts fam
men have kinks
have
kids brother
what is all of this
what is all of this brother um she's
made 38 bags from fighting in a jar
mandom are just buying it she's shipping
that out
that's mad to be fair though
ugh
uh what it's not that many farts
if you think about it
it's not that many farts she's she's a
grand a
that's 380 farts brother oh you said 38
bags she made 38 bags yeah 38 grand
and she sells it for a grand yeah that's
only 38 farts
there's only three of us she made 38
grand that's it yeah yeah yeah that's
only 38 pops yeah i was thinking of 380.
that's a morning for me
that's a thursday morning
[Laughter]
nah so yeah that's like 38 a week oh
okay oh okay 38 bags a week
for how many weeks we don't know we
don't know there's no time for okay all
right
that's better yeah because i say that's
not that many pops bro
38 grand a week
from fighting in bottles
what i want to know is does it actually
still stink
i think it will
if you fall in a jar and tighten i think
it will well how quickly you have to
tighten it i don't i don't know but i
think it has to be very quick
but it has to be i'm just thinking of
like how is she farting in the jar and
then doing this and doing this fam no
one knows
because in the jar as well it's got
there's sighting in the jar i should put
something else in there i think she put
something else to keep like a scent i
don't know this there's sighting in the
jar it looks like a dead moth
oh it does is that paul pereira sign i
bet it's [ __ ] potpourri i bet it is
the [ __ ] i bet she thinks that's the
truth i bet she genuinely thinks
her [ __ ] don't sting yeah and she
actually thinks like
this probably complements the flowery
scent
yeah yeah yeah yeah trump
she's
shut up then again obviously
it's based on a diet oh yeah i've seen
the video of her saying like
in order she's disgusting bro i've heard
like um it was another podcast i saw
covering this and they were base like
they played a video of her like talking
about like oh this is what i do and then
i get the requests and then um
she sends them like a nice handwritten
note or whatever and then maybe she puts
that in the jar as well fam she eats
certain things and she says like oh this
is what i eat to get the farts brewing
or cooking or she uses a term that i was
like
i can imagine i can already imagine her
stomach bubbling oh fam i don't know
what
she would do i reckon it's probably
things i don't know because i know what
makes you [ __ ]
i don't know what makes you fart
so i don't know but it's probably bare
beans just legumes probably yeah just
mad lagoons bro some edamame's yeah yeah
yeah she's popping okay
i'm not buying someone's fart especially
for that level of peep
that's why i'm saying mandem have kinks
brother
this is what i'm saying to you james i
want to buy it for a tenner let alone a
bag you can pay me to have it
you've got to give me a tenner and say
hey
take this far
no
no way it doesn't make sense how is she
even
how is she how has she marketed this
i don't know i see that's the thing i
don't know i'm assuming the origin story
is she was getting nasty dms yeah and
someone said i will pay you a bag for a
bottle of your fart and she said that's
one i can do
that one i can do
and then
he sent the thing on cash app or
whatever
and then here we are here we are she had
she was
obligated she had to pop in there and
she fought [ __ ] i was easy
but like yeah i don't know does she
require like evidence that she's done it
exactly like how are we meant to know if
i've purchased a jar how am i meant to
know it's actually her fault yeah i want
to know i want to see the video of how
we need proof i need you to write my
name
like i want okay i want a sticky note on
the jar with my name on it and then i
want to see you pop in it
seal it and send it to me
that's the other way that's the only
that's i need that verification
otherwise you're not having my money
you can hold that [ __ ] because you ain't
having my money what are these man fam
the king when it arrives
they gassed and they just they must be
thinking all right how can i save it
save yeah
because they can't lay it all out yeah
they can't just open it i just i'm
thinking
today are they like
all right imagine just one of these and
ready just one of these all right
yeah so
they must have to like oh no it's a
screw top here's a screw top but let's
go with one of these yeah so maybe
they're just like
that
like every so often but obviously let's
let's be honest she she's so naive that
she pretends to not know that it's a
sexual thing for starters annoys me of
course
but i'm thinking are these man naked in
bed ready or do they or can they not
contain themselves and they have to
smell it now like is it fuel for the
fire yeah do they sniff it
and then go in their bed put some horn
on
them
or are they thinking
i want this
on my phone i need it all over me while
i'm walking i've neat i've waited for
this all week
kind of thing yeah basically is what
you're saying i'm waiting for this all
week he opens it and the whole room
explodes yeah he's engulfed in far yeah
yeah and he's just in euphoria
yuck
kings man mandem have kinks that
post nut clarity must be terrifying
terrifying not only
not only have i just wanked to a fart
i've spent a bag on it
i've spent a whole bag on it what am i
going to tell my missus
what am i going to say what am i going
to do my finances are dodging i was lost
in the drama of it and now i've knotted
and i've just got a jar on my face
there's there's not everywhere i think
and
and then you get a dm from her like did
you enjoy it
i know you want to do it again oh of
course bro
and you just want to do it again you
don't look at your phone for an hour at
least then once you've showered
recuperated and you've got your sense
what you think is your sense like
your talking around too and she says
like hi babe like how was it
oh we're going again we're going again
we're going again i've sent you a
deposit for the next shipment
we're going again as soon as i hear that
article she's in hospital i'm vexed
i'm vexed because now you have to look
for another thing
her farts are reliable yeah they're
reliable and they smell good they come
in a nice package it's personalized oh
that's a kink oh that mandem have kinks
because
it just doesn't this is why they've got
kings and they've always got who's got
money for this i don't know
i don't know it's always them hoarders
from random [ __ ] like that but this is
how i know
sex is like
i don't know how to explain the word sex
is
is far from what my comprehension is if
that makes sense it means
so many different things to other people
yes bro it means way more than you could
ever
think that's that yeah absolutely the
actual act of it this is just the the
tip of the ice yes there's so much more
psychology to it and the behavior
patterns and the yeah there's depths to
it bro from when you can buy a fart from
someone and it's worth a grand to you
yeah bro sex is different for different
people speaking of sex this ties in very
well with the next segment so we're
going to go into last week or a few
weeks ago i asked um or we asked the
group chat the group chat we asked the
fandom on ig what are your worst sexual
encounters
and we got a lot of feedback obviously
you guys that follow us saw on the story
the ones that we posted but there were
so many
i saved them for the show so here we go
he answered at work he answered a work
call for a meet in mid-stroke and just
carried on in the same rhythm no change
that's that has to happen sometimes
it's never happened to me but i can see
it happening
i reckon he thought
it was cool
he thought he would look cool as well
yeah yeah and i bet he thought like
because there's been times
where
i've been somewhere like it's happened
both times like there's been times where
i've been on the phone to someone and
the girl i'm with at the time has just
tried to suck me off mm-hmm because she
thinks it's funny and there's been the
opposite time but she's been on the
phone i'm eating pump there's nothing
you can say to stop me and then
everyone's trying to keep their
composure yeah you're probably thinking
i'm going to answer the call and keep
banging yeah and then i'm going to see
if she can keep quiet on her she was
thinking get off me and get me out
you don't care about me
you don't want to be
here that's a paradox
my friend
my friend was giving this guy head and
ripped the skin off his shaft and it
bled everywhere
that
is not head that's not embarrassing
that's not nothing that's i don't want
to hear that
that's not head
that's not
weed
james
if i'm get i'm standing up if i'm
getting a blowy
and i feel like a cut from the teeth
i don't know what my reaction would be
run
you know those you know that electricity
game where you're trying to run the
thing around the little the maze bit
yeah so it doesn't touch the sides yeah
that would be how i exit my my tool from
my mouth is how that would have to be
as soon as i feel that sharp um
and it has to go in a straight line
100
that's hilarious that's crazy that's
hilarious oh my days
oh
my ex at the exact moment he finished
he let out the loudest fire and it
echoed in a bathroom
are they banging in the bathroom
there must have been oh sorry echoed in
the bedroom i don't know i said bathroom
yeah fam i don't know why i said
bathroom
i don't know why i said boyfriend that's
grim he
he was in such relief
he just relaxed his whole body oh boy
just went ah
he relaxed his whole body i just
oh everything oh yeah that must have
been sweet joy for him yeah bittersweet
yeah
sweet yeah once the clarity washed over
him he was in hell but for those few
seconds it was the best moment
one of them ones
front and back same time that simultane
nah
he was in euphoria ah i can't imagine i
can't imagine
oh my days i farted when i came in her
mouth we both laughed i felt so bad
that's him
that's actually embarrassing that is
embarrassing that's actually
embarrassing came in her mouth and then
you're fighting
and she's laughing she's just there
just there
now bro that's great
that's [ __ ]
nah man no ah him saying his arm is
getting tired while fingering me
literally after two minutes
that is embarrassing but i sympathize
i sympathize because as a my forearm fan
sometimes
especially the position
especially the position because that's
not putting into consideration that's
not there's been times where i've had a
chick
on top say let's say i'm i'm clothed
yeah i'm clothed yeah but she's starters
now yeah yeah yeah or we're doing a
little sighting yeah yeah yeah action
yeah she's on top she's lips and i'm
going for the stinky pink
bro in this position
here yeah to get the full rotation at
your wrist yeah at the the vertical
right angle that you're looking for here
[Music]
to keep that going yeah yeah it's hell i
can imagine is hell bro i feel like if i
look down i'm just gonna see veins
bursting it's hell bro and you can do it
for like
i don't know 30 seconds and then i'm
like
and i'm there just shattered i don't
want nothing to do with this anymore
that's hilarious that's hilarious
i know exactly what you mean oh my days
um
random one night stand we [ __ ] he then
took a [ __ ] and left
nah that's not okay
that's not why you're looking at me like
that
that's not okay
that's not okay
i was riding i was riding reverse cargo
r spread turned around and the bro was
just watching tv
yeah right dude
[Music]
uh uh
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it'd be like that
sometimes
it'd be like it'd literally be like that
sometimes
you can you can want two things at once
they're just they're doing the most
and they look back i didn't see you
watching rick and morty i have to see
this [ __ ]
i can't have something i love in the
background yeah whilst i'm making it
yeah yeah you know you should have let
me turn it off before this is your fault
yeah yeah yeah 100
rick and morty you know i'm gonna pay
attention autonomously it's not my fault
i've seen every episode yeah it's gonna
bank
oh jesus
oh
when he came he said dunsky
that's funny that's actually funny
dunsky you know
he had two pairs of boxers on and i said
what sorry he had two pairs of boxes on
and said i'm one of those guys that
wears two
i'm sorry what that's literally what you
said i'm sorry what i've never heard
that in my life that's not a thing
that's not a thing i'm one of those guys
i'm the guy i am the only guy that wears
two
that's random this has to be a lie
i was [ __ ] with my ex his dad caught
us and then joined in that is lie that
is a lie that is a lie that was like 100
that's the girl that's in there really
yeah that's a lie that's a fantasy and a
lie two in one yeah
when he's stripped naked and he's fully
clothed then says sorry i can't do this
wait oh when you are
that made me sweat no found the way that
took a second to sink in i could tell i
saw it in your face oh that's jokes
sorry i can't do this
nah
nah
that's jokes
oh that's jokes
that is hilarious
oh my goodness that's too funny man
that's the funniest one you've said
easily that's the funniest one you've
said
left my glasses by her bed and went to
the toilet and got stuck and it got
stuck in the toilet a different guy kept
blowing his nose while i was while he
was doing me and doggy
a different guy wouldn't be a different
guy oh she sent more than one sorry oh
okay cool so first one
one guy
come on go on go on going one guy threw
up in the middle of eating me out
that's disgusting
wow
he wasn't about it at all fam i don't
even know how to register that because
be here i've seen
i've obviously seen many of the ones
where girls are giving guys head and
they are
like
you've got something actually
choking your throat triggering your
tonsils i so understandable yeah you
know but when it's the other way around
he just hated the whole experience
to him it was like
it was basically like me saying like how
much to do x
basically and then and that was x you
were x yeah yeah yeah you got down to it
and your box was x
confirm it
i stared at his tool and pre and
proceeded to say you sure you ain't
mixed he's asian
i think that's a compliment that sounds
more of a compliment no it's not family
i stared at his tall
and you proceeded to say are you sure
you're not mixed oh he's asian aesthetic
he's always saying
not mixed
racist
so he's basically saying he had a bigger
tool and asian guys don't have big tools
but basically it's racist but yeah a
compliment yeah
yeah yeah it's a slap in the forehead
basically
yeah yeah yeah
switching to hitting doggy style
as i stood up
as i stood up at the end of the bed i
stepped in her dog's [ __ ]
damn that's disgusting damn that's a
poor household
that yeah yeah that's a poor house that
is yeah that's great
after we finished she said she would be
she said she would be my side her if i
ever broke
up with her i got i saw that one i've
had a girl say that to me
what
yeah just like if we ever break up like
you're basically i think the premise is
like she's trying to tell him like yo
like
if we ever break up just know you're
gonna keep banging me yeah i don't care
if you've got a new girlfriend or
whatever you're going to keep banging me
i reckon a lot of girls have said that
in that when their minds twisted i
reckon bear goes there because i've had
yeah i've had it said to me before
i saw that when it didn't surprise me in
the slightest
i used the light on my watch to see what
the 90 looked like in the dark
i'm son ben tenting man clicked
yo
that's funny you man are nasty bro
jokes
oh that's hilarious
certain man our children bro
certain man our children
a man said i [ __ ] also winked at me
bruv what does that even mean oh yuck
right i just rolled
um
we've talked about this one before
called me his ex-girlfriend twice second
time i've stopped him and he started
crying wow
that's that's shameful that is very
shameful
was doing doggy and he paused and said
do you believe in god
i would be so
rattled
if i'm just stopped just stop the whole
thing stop
there's certain things that we talk
about in these kind of scenarios and i
think like
what do these men look like and how many
girls are they banging their life
because clearly you
are getting so much love from the
opposite sex that you think is
appropriate to just start saying [ __ ]
like you're so used to this that you
think you can just say [ __ ] yeah and it
is whatever
[ __ ] hell oh my days
slashed my tool on her nails while she
was
while she played
this guy can't write slashed my tool
on her nails
while she's playing with her
kitty cat
bled a little and then faded in the
bathroom
bro
that's embarrassing as well bro that is
embarrassing
wow
called me mummy whilst whilst we were
doing the business first and last time
i'll ever hit a younger guy
mommy mommy
mommy
mommy
mommy mommy you know oh
that's that makes me feel sick
my bro was staring at me mid train and i
lost focus
let me [ __ ] my half of her body bro
that's funny that's funny funny funny
focus on my half you know
elbowed the man in the nose by mistake
during doggy and popped his nose ouch
that scream ouch that scream
oh fam to be fair let me stop you there
there was once
one i saw there was one i saw that
is similar to what you said about the
um
similar to what you said about the
flipping
she was doing um reverse cow
and she looked back and my mum was
watching tv
it said
um
he said like basically yeah
he was eating pom
no yeah yeah there was a song playing
yeah he was eating pum and there was a
song playing in the back and he stopped
to sing the chorus
bro you reposted that one i don't even
remember
song playing in the bag and you stopped
to sing the chorus and it made me
howl bro
i made me how rock and i was thinking
what soul could it have possibly been i
don't know to make me just stop one do
it and think [ __ ] it man i was
in there romance in there
like i think
this this is the song we love but
there's there's certain songs that i was
actually i actually deeped i had like a
long five minute thing to myself i was
thinking you know what there's actually
certain songs
that would make me do it that would have
to be like i don't care where i am yeah
yeah
out bro
if i was in there i was imagine if i'm
in there
and then i hear a little pretty ricky
all right let's start okay you give me
the pretty rickies and then uh let me
let me let me compose myself let me
imagine on there okay all right three
two one action i'm there
[Music]
it's
[Applause]
bro i'd have to
she would she would peel back on the bed
like what's going on and you can't hit
me with that
that hotline
you can't hit that oh oh
okay i'm balling it
down whack it enough
it's fun
that's hilarious i have there's certain
songs that hit you too hard bro i know
what you mean i know what you mean [ __ ]
yeah there's certain songs that hit you
too hard that one would slap me
probably
um
i'm outside
hey
she'll be like you're feeling this too
much [ __ ] concentrated
but yeah bro [ __ ] that was a funny
brand when you posted that was a funny
thing
bro i loved it thank you guys for that
man thank you we've got loads more but
we'll do another week yeah i might even
repost them later on all right guys
um
right
and someone sent it to us and i had to i
had to had to read it
this one
i've seen something similar to this
before
i went through my girl's insta dms
and it was her attempting to cheat on me
multiple times and just getting aired
and violated by guys
i think i saw this i want to break up
with her out of pure embarrassment i
don't even care about the cheating
that
i couldn't stomach that bro i didn't see
that but i saw something very similar
but i understand that egg
as that's the biggest sick of all time
as
well as disrespectful as disrespectful
as it is to find your girl wanting to
cheat on you the fact that she's not
even getting any responses reflects
badly on you i'm the joke i'm the joke
oh i'm with the clown basically
my girl's so busted
my girl's so clapped that she can't even
cheat on me she's moving to guys freeing
up the nanny and they're saying no
they're saying you're clapped what does
that say about me says the worst about
me
i'm not a man i need to get out of this
i need to get out of this i couldn't say
that's so that's so embarrassing that's
hell ever embarrassing that's the most
embarrassing thing i can imagine [ __ ]
man you're so butters bro
that you can't even cheat on man what
good are you to me
what good are you talking about
you can't even
change nah it reminds me of this back
when we used to watch made in chelsea
back in the days remember uni times we
used to watch you know what you know i
know what you're gonna say spencer my
guy spencer
how can i respect you when you allow me
to cheat on you
he said on tower bridge like it was
nothing i couldn't believe it how can i
respect you when you allow me to cheat
on you
i couldn't believe that clip when i saw
it she had no option but to slit his
throat
[Laughter]
that's the only way out of that
conversation with your head held high
you've got no option to slice his throat
right on top right on tower bridge
that's all you've got left
because otherwise what can you do
by saying you i bet you're you're gonna
go home and cry about something
something stupid like that something
stupid wasn't saying matthew's
i'm pretty sure it's my i can't remember
spencer from made in chelsea is the most
disrespect he's a guy a villain
he's a villain but he owns it that's
what i love about him
he owns it owns it
[ __ ] yeah what a guy you have to rate
the fact that he owns it so hard oh how
can i respect you when you allow me to
just what's her name i can see her face
it's my man's sister something thompson
i have no idea what her name is
her face i mean she's cute she's very
small yeah sounds posh london name yeah
or some [ __ ]
there's a yellow neck or tilly in it i
don't know there definitely is i don't
know why they've had so many different
characters now bro spence
spencer yeah he was a villain and he
said that with chess chat of course like
say it wasn't he said it like say it
wasn't in his head before he said it
he said it like he knew he wasn't at
fault well like say like she's banging
on about respect and man's thinking
respect is she crazy
how can i speak to you you just allow me
to run out and bang yes
and you do nothing about it
you're a joke
you come back to me all the time you
always run back and you want respect you
don't respect yourself
how can i respect you when you allow
allow allow
the producers when they heard that must
have been
[ __ ] i couldn't be i couldn't be that
cameraman i couldn't be that cameraman
no i'm there and i'm on camera one bro
and i've got that shot
oh the you know the boom mic yeah the
guy that's just holding the thing there
if i've got that
i said i didn't i didn't hear that right
how can i respect you when you allow me
to cheat on you bro you'll see the boom
might drop in front of the camera you'll
see a drop what did you say oh scream
i'll be
howling fam
he's the og he is he was anyways
you allow this villain this heartache
you're living through it's your fault
it's your fault of course i'm going to
cheat
you facilitate my team
she facilitates is cheating
i couldn't believe it when i heard it
i couldn't believe it when i heard it
villain that's the it's one of the
cleanest lines i've ever heard on any tv
show any form of reality show any show
bro how can i respect you when you allow
me to cheat on you
oh
there's no words there are no words
speechless and then he said and i need
to know what he said next in fact she
had no option but to slice his jugular
on the spot that's all she has if she
wants to retain any sort of strength in
the in that situation you have to murder
him
that's all there is left because then he
tells you to [ __ ] off and cry and then
you just skip home
to his mansion
oh you have to shoot him in his head
there's nothing left jesus that's um
that was funny a girl could
never say that to me
we'd have to scrap because i'm
i i
can't speak because i wouldn't be able
to speak in that moment yeah i know what
you mean
because unfathomable she took in that
one sentence he took everything from her
yeah it's unfathomable yeah everything
how can like
yeah you don't deserve respect
because you can't even keep your partner
faithful
and i'm him
so i know
i'm him
and i'm really nearly cheating on you
and you do [ __ ] all about it
you're a joke
you're a joke to be fair
i wasn't i wasn't this harsh one time
but years ago
um
i'm laughing it's not funny
years ago i um
i had a girlfriend
and i chewed on them
and i wasn't proud about it but it was
what it was um
and then when it was all said and done
she kind of we went through it
and then she was just like
ah okay well like
she basically said uh i'm gonna take you
back but it's fine it's whatever it's
like i'm not happy about it but whatever
and i'm just saying
and this is a space this is all within
the space of like five minutes
okay we had like
she clocked had the argument
the argument and then
she was just like fine like i guess
we'll move on
and i was like
no
she was like what do you mean and i was
like
no like
basically what special said like yeah
no like just just know like yeah yeah
yeah no rate yourself
rate yourself it's been four minutes and
38 seconds and you're already you're
taking me back you're taking it i didn't
even ask you
but no though because you don't rate
yourself and no offense i don't want a
girlfriend who doesn't write this up
she didn't know what to say
damn she didn't know what to say damn
and i was like bro like
harsh but true bro like what do you mean
yeah
that's cheap it was yesterday yeah
the wounds are still fresh i didn't even
showered i ain't even showered
like
rate yourself down like i can't be this
high
in your like i think the way the way my
brain was working at that time was like
she clearly doesn't see us as equals
she sees me here and she's lucky to be
here
that's clearly the from the way you're
acting in the situation you see me here
you're heartbroken
but you're like i can't lose this and
it's like it's already gone
like
the only way you can get some power back
in your life is if we break up because
what are you taking me back for i don't
deserve it you think so little of
yourself that you think i deserve to
have you back
less than 24 hours after i've done the
deed
like that's poor rate yourself
bye
good day good day
good day to you you must go now damn
[Music]
she didn't write itself in the slightest
throat yeah it was cut through it had to
be that's beautiful yeah it had to be
cut throat but yeah clearly she wouldn't
have understood it any other way
considering she was willing to take you
back without you asking yeah and what
did we do just pick up where we left off
and plus
i was also under the the thing of like
you can't like it you haven't processed
anything or whatever like i'm not
gonna get into a situation now where
you're telling me what i can and can't
do that was the other side of it it's
like this
like granted i [ __ ] up and all this
stuff but i would rather
cut the whole thing now
rather than remold this relationship
into some insecure
hell hole yeah of like you think it's
okay to check my phone or tell me where
i can i can't go and use this as a
loaded gun to control my actions it's
not it's not gonna happen the whole
thing's done of course just know just to
know the whole thing's done of course of
course of course but yeah um
i think that's it i think that is i
think that's it bro so guys
you know what to do yeah ma'am soon as
this finishes head on over to
patreon.com forward slash hits and gigs
jump in with us on thursday let's have
some more fun vibes um but yeah if
you're still here we appreciate you
um leave a like leave a comment and uh
guys thank you so much for being here
with us
it's 2022 he's off to a good start it is
a few episodes i've had a great time
yeah scoffs are really good i hope you
guys are feeling the love as well hope
you guys having a great year great month
you know yo man we look forward to
seeing you soon i have a thursday if
you're not part of the gang we'll see
you on monday yeah man love love
[Music]